[Music]
[Music]
i think bill cosby's the biggest
comedian of all time oh do you yeah
yeah i don't think anyone will ever
match his
production and quality of material
do you like bill cosby i love bill cosby
yeah did you listen to those records
when you were a kid sure
no one cares about movies anymore no one
goes to cinema no one really watches
network tv
everyone's watching netflix this show
should just be me coming out going well
done netflix you win
everything good night but no no we gotta
drag it out for three
hours you could binge watch the entire
first season of afterlife
instead of watching this show that
that's a show about a man
who wants to kill himself because his
wife dies of cancer
and it's still more fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end
he obviously didn't kill himself just
like jeffrey epstein
shut up i know he's your friend but i
don't care
and that's why i don't trip off being a
celebrity i don't like it
i don't trust it there's one minute they
all love you the next thing you know
in front of that courthouse dancing on
top of a car just trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] happened to you
[Applause]
that's what i'm waiting for the timing
of this michael jackson [ __ ] is what
makes me doubt it
every time this war is going out of
control the economy gets bad or
something is wrong with the world at
large
it's always these moments in history
that
michael jackson will coincidentally jerk
awful kid this is getting
ridiculous like are you planning this
[ __ ] do you have meetings
michael thank you for coming as you know
michael the war has not been going as
well as we expected there's been a lot
of hiccups
and the public is asking us a lot of
questions of course
and well michael there's no nice way to
say this
and all i know how to do is be direct so
let me just be direct
we're gonna need you to jerk off another
child mike i'm sorry
i am sorry
but it would really help out
or maybe he didn't who knows who knows
that's the thing that's what i wanted to
say who knows who the [ __ ] knows
mike god and this little boy know that's
that's about it
that's about it the only reason that i
can even
talk about this [ __ ] is because
everybody is
speculating they all think he did it and
i don't think he did it i'm alone in
this
i don't think he did it i'm not gonna
say i don't think he did it that's too
strong
[Music]
let me just say i am reserving judgment
until all the facts come out but so far
from what i heard i mean the kid said he
was dying of cancer
he was in make-a-wish foundation he
claims he had two weeks to live
and it was his dying wish
to meet michael jackson come on man give
me a [ __ ] break
this kid is 10 years old he don't
remember thriller the [ __ ] you want to
meet michael jackson for honestly
i remember thrilling i just like kind of
want to meet this thing
like i wouldn't break an appointment i
mean if i put it that way
i'd have to already be free that's
ridiculous like if i'm dying in two
weeks and go oh mama
oh get me in the room with chubby
chuckle
i wouldn't want to meet that
[ __ ] my last two weeks why not
usher
somebody like this so then the kid
claims
he goes to michael's house this is where
it all gets crazy i don't
like you know he does everything you'd
expect at michael's house they uh
climbed trees and rode roller coasters
and ferris wheels the chef made cookies
pies and cakes
they was petting the monkey and giraffes
sing songs
kid [ __ ] and in the middle of all this
childlike activity
for some reason mike pulled out some
wine and some pills
[Applause]
and sucked this kid's dick folks it
hurts me to say
the kid had the nerve to call that abuse
[ __ ] that is a good host god
damn what else do you want
what else do you want
[Applause]
i'm lucky to get a glass of a great
drink at my friend's house
let alone a roller coaster ride my dick
sucked
mike must be confused like i brought you
in my house i bet you
i suck your dick and this is how you
repay me [ __ ]
this was your wish that man
thought you were dying in two weeks what
happened to that [ __ ]
i've been in court for a year and a half
to get strong every time i see you
wouldn't be some ironic [ __ ] if they
found out through this case that the
cure for cancer
was michael jackson sucking your dick
somehow
like if mike had power was like green
mile and all the kids like please mike
suck out x
never again he didn't appreciate it
can we at least study your saliva
please mike
it just doesn't stop though it just
doesn't stop
and the only reason i could talk about
mike is because he's a freak
he's a freak that's why people let you
talk about
because if i brought up catholic priests
[ __ ] kids it'll get quiet as [ __ ]
but but when michael jackson does it
it's okay
because he's a freak his face is all cut
up but just remember when you look at
that
thing that he calls his face that he did
that for you somehow
somehow he thought you might maybe it'll
help maybe people will like me more
if i turn myself into a white ghoulish
like creature i don't know what the [ __ ]
it is
but he did it for you and i appreciate
the gesture michael jackson if you're
watching this
i appreciate that justin and i want you
to know [ __ ] everybody
dave chappelle understands because you
want to know something
i'm getting some work done surprise yes
nothing major you would never know if i
didn't tell you but it's some [ __ ] i'm
insecure
about that i want to work on if you must
know
i'm getting botox done on my bowls to
get these wrinkles out
finally i can have these as smooth as
eggs
no i can't wait i
read that you have you have actually
annoyed
one of your idols who is that oh the
great bill
cosby yeah what'd you do oh my god i
love that guy he's my hero you know just
like you
maybe joy or bill clinton would be your
hero
i i love i love
there's no stopping you isn't it no you
seem to like bill clinton
and this man leads into our show on
friday night
i know so right his career is over after
this anyway who cares
go ahead norman no bill clinton who's a
great man obviously
you know everybody has their opinions
right mm-hmm are you moving along
oh god carter's
bill cosby is a great man first time
there has never been
any accusations towards bill cosby about
anything you just tell us what you did
bill cosby
oh i i met him i i opened for him at
a club and he was a great man you know
he's my hero of all time you know how
funny bill cosby yeah so get to the
point
i'm going past menopause
or shall i ask you the next thing well
the bill cosby thing is this dear guys
i uh met bill cosby we're all fans of
bill cosby right
burma yeah what yeah why are we talking
about the millionaire
[Applause]
actually nerd jesus died in the last
year right
steve jobs yeah he died right
i know i know a lot of nerds here
tonight i know you're sad
i didn't get it i didn't get the big
deal they made about that guy
when he died they were like he changed
the world
it wasn't safe he changed the world
the world was one way and then steve
jobs came
and it was another what did he do
somebody for the love of god what the
[ __ ] did that guy
do what did he do he told other people
what to invent
i want my entire music collection in
that phone
get on it
[Applause]
right and then these poor nameless
faceless scientists got to go in the
back room and figure it out
what the [ __ ] are we going to get all of
this into this i mean
what year does this guy think this is
this is crazy this is like
buck rogers dude my kid has her birthday
in like 11 months
steve jobs just walking by i don't hear
any thinking going on in there
just strutting around the office eating
some pretentious fruit like a pear
right just throwing out ideas
there's another one there's another one
i just came up with on the way to work i
was reading a magazine the other day
turning pages you know i like to turn
pages on a screen that aren't even there
yeah wrap your [ __ ] heads around that
guys
see you in eight years where you going
michael big little
big little get on it
right then all these people slave away
to make his vision come true and then
they have the big nerd fest
right down there comic con and all their
nerd mecca they're all showing up with
their acne
and their hulk shirts limping into the
arena
right does steve jobs go out with the
whole chorus line of scientists now he
goes out there by himself
and no belt like it was no biggie right
[Applause]
like he's like he's tesla
tapping into the atmosphere i know this
is always uncomfortable i know you
bought into it right
that whole advertising the way they
aligned themselves with some of the
greatest people of all time
jesus gandhi me
remember that muhammad ali john lennon
this guy
how the [ __ ] was that dude like any of
them
gandhi didn't have a sweatshop
ah he didn't have people leaping to
their deaths only to get
catch a net and get ricocheted back
through the window
to have to put together yet another ipad
john lennon didn't have children in his
basement pressing those
[ __ ] albums
i know i know
new phone can't fit the old charger this
is your hero
this is the guy this is what all the
silence is about
new phone can't fit the old charger so
then you got to throw it out ends up in
the ocean around some octopuses neck
do you realize how much sea life is
ecstatic that that man is no longer
walking the earth
that's where it all ends up you know it
doesn't go into landfill ends up in the
ocean
you realize that i hate people who say i
don't pollute i don't pollute yeah you
do
you use [ __ ] and you throw it out what
do you think cause you put in like a
basket it just poof disappears
[Applause]
everything he ever used is somewhere
even think about that remember that
flannel shirt you bought back in the day
when you got into pearl jam
that's out there somewhere probably on
some porpoises face
trying to get it off stupid little
flippers
all the fads you remember rollerblading
remember that everybody had them we set
up
cones we did little tricks right one
little homophobic joke
killed that entire fat
what's the hardest thing about
rollerblading telling your parents
you're gay
grown adults dude i'm not gay i don't
have the cooties these mean i
suck dick and they just threw them out
they end up in the ocean they're made
out of plastic they can't bio-degrade
they just break down the little cubes
fish are breathing them in
six months later you're going out you're
getting sushi you think you're being
healthy
you're eating your old rollerblades all
right i'm out of time you guys are great
thank you
thank you thank you